gypsy rose blanchard gets married in
prison e.t can confirm the 30 year old
tied the knot with ryan scott anderson
in missouri on june 27 amid the 10-year
prison sentence she's currently serving
little is known about gypsy's new
husband but according to their marriage
license we know ryan hails from
louisiana but ryan wasn't gypsy's first
serious romance in prison she was
previously engaged to a man named ken in
2019 they met through the prison's pen
pal program but the two called it off
that same year
gypsy is currently serving time in
prison for the 2015 murder of her mother
dede blanchard
how would you describe your mom
um
[Music]
unique
um
i mean i used to always think that maybe
she's a little overprotective and so if
i had to
say one word about her it would be
overprotective
didi suffered from munchausen syndrome
by proxy and manipulated gypsy into
thinking she needed a wheelchair and was
suffering from a series of chronic
illnesses what illnesses did your mom
say that you had
um
asthma
epilepsy
um hearing impaired vision impaired
fed with a feeding tube paralyzed from
the waist down after years of suffering
gypsy met nicholas gouda john online
they formed a relationship and concocted
a plan to kill didi which they did in
2015. in 2019 their story was turned
into a mini-series called the act
starring joey king and patricia arquette
i wonder what it would look like if it
grew in
i'll be a rat's nest like mine
to be able to portray a story like this
it's really a once-in-a-lifetime type of
opportunity and it means the world going
into something like this with all that
support behind you i i've it's been such
a really just
great experience joey who completely
transformed for this role spoke to e.t
on set and explained why the public's
perception of gypsy might change after
watching the series there's a lot of
like different opinions out there a lot
of people are like oh
i don't sympathize with her at all she
murdered somebody and that's wrong and
then there's other people who are out
there who are like wow
this girl went through so much i can't
believe she's in prison and
i really think
both parties are going to come out of
this show with a new perspective of
gypsy especially the people who think
that she you know
deserves to just sit in prison i i mean
when you see what this girl went through
in 2016 gypsy pled guilty to
second-degree murder and will be
eligible for parole in 2024 as for
nicholas he was convicted of
first-degree murder in 2018 and is
currently serving a life sentence